One of the most surprising things about Japan
– and there are many surprising things – is
how safe it is.
See, Japan is one of the few countries in
the world where you can leave an iPhone X
[Ten] in a coffee shop and not have to worry
about anything but dropping by the next day.
Because, my friends, it is almost certain
that your recently released, brand new iPhone
X will be there waiting for you.
And no, I'm not exaggerating.
Also, Japan, is just a beautiful country with
amazing sites, where everything seems to be
where it should be.
But...
As you know this isn’t a travel channel...
and this video isn’t sponsored by Japan’s
Ministry of Tourism, so... let’s get to
the point.
Recently we found out that Emperor Akihito
has decided to abdicate.
(“The emperor of Japan will step down on
April 30, 2019, the first abdication by a
Japanese monarch in two centuries”.
New York Times.)
Well, see: this emperor came to the throne
almost 30 years ago, in 1989...
Just when the great Japanese crisis began.
No, in Japan the emperor has no power, so
Akihito wasn’t responsible, but don’t
say that can’t be just coincidence and bad
luck.
We can practically say that it was after Akihito’s
arrival that 30 years of stagnation began.
In this video we will see what happened, what
caused this great crisis and why the German
economic model has managed to defeat the Japanese
model.
But first, my friends, a small history lesson.
(MIRACLES EXIST)
Japan and Germany are two very interesting
countries, with a lot in common and, also,
many differences.
After the Second World War both countries
were literally in ruins.
They had lost not only their infrastructure,
but also an entire generation.
However, despite this, between the 1950s and
the 1970s, both countries experienced such
a powerful takeoff that in those two decades
they not only managed to recover, but to become
two of the largest economies in the world,
as well as two of the richest countries.
In fact, even though it might seem incredible
today, for years it was speculated that Japan
could surpass even the United States as the
world's largest economy.
How things have changed!
The fact is that between 1955 and 1973 Japan
grew at an annual average rate of 9%, and
between 1973 and 1990, above 4%.
These truly are some incredible rates.
And Germany, didn’t stay behind, it had
average annual growth of 7% for almost 30
years.
Both countries were at full throttle.
Their factories worked tirelessly, there was
no unemployment, and both Germans and the
Japanese saved and invested their money all
over the world.
Suddenly, Japanese and German companies became
famous worldwide.
This was very important, especially for Japan,
a country that lives constantly under nature’s
threat...
Besides being a very mountainous country,
Japan suffers from all kinds of natural disasters:
earthquakes, cyclones, tsunamis, etc, etc.
By the way, in future VISUALPOLITIK videos,
we will tell you all about how these two "economic
miracles" took place.
Well, the fact is that in 1989 this entire
economic takeoff stopped, it came to an end
and gave way to what is now known as the great
Japanese stagnation.
(“Forget Greece, Japan is the world's real
economic time bomb” Christopher Matthews,
an Axios reporter.)
I’m convinced, this isn’t news to you,
as it isn’t strange to hear people talk
about Japan along with the word crisis.
Yes, ever since I can recall, Japan has been
the country of eternal crisis, the country
that has one good year for every three bad
ones.
In fact, nowadays we can easily declare Germany
the winner in the growth race that both countries
maintained for decades.
See, today Germany – which has also gone
through some bad times in recent decades – is
richer, has healthier public accounts, is
more competitive internationally and has higher
wages.
To get an idea of Japan’s situation, I think
we can use two very revealing facts.
First, in Japan real wages, taking inflation
into account, are lower today than salaries
back in 1990, 30 years ago!
And second, the Japanese government’s public
debt is the highest in the world: 250% of
the GDP, yes 250%, you heard that right.
So my friends, you might be wondering, what
the hell happened?
What made the German model so much better
than the Japanese model?
Well... obviously, there are lots of reasons,
but we believe that 3 of them are, by far,
the most important.
Let's take a look at them.
(A PROBLEMATIC MODEL)
First, we can say that there was a big difference
between Japan and Germany’s development.
The country of the rising sun, opted to protect
large industrial conglomerates, the 'Keiretsu'.
The keiretsu are, so to speak, holdings that
do practically everything, that is, they have
companies for all kinds of things: cars, planes,
tires, toothpaste...
Everything is manufactured by the same holding
company, whose companies support each other,
buy and sell products between them and even
have their own banks to finance themselves.
So what’s the problem with this?
Well... these large conglomerates tended to
be very bureaucratic and not very flexible.
So decision-making was a difficult and very
slow process.
But...
The Japanese government decided to compensate
for all these disadvantages, and didn’t
hesitate to give the keiretsu all kinds of
advantages and privileges.
For example, Japan’s Central Bank financed
them generously at abnormally low rates through
specific programs.
However, my friends, the results weren’t
at all good.
See, these large groups became very influential
in the country’s politics;
they hid many problems, because of course,
when one of these conglomerates’ companies
did badly, it was extremely easy for them
to infect the rest;
they were in a lot of debt; and they even
limited competition.
Of course, how can one compete with such groups,
if they are also protected by the government
and have all kinds of privileges?
Sounds hard, right?
On the other hand, in Germany, the political
commitment was completely different and focused
on creating a very competitive market with
small and medium sized companies.
But, are there large industrial groups in
Germany?
Of course, and that's a good thing, as long
as they don’t depend on the government or
receive privileges that impede competition.
So while Germany’s companies thrived, Japan’s
large conglomerates have had many problems,
and most have disappeared or broken down at
some point.
But that’s not all...
(THE DISCOUNT POLICY)
For years, Japanese politicians thought that
in order to export more, devaluing the currency
from time to time... wasn’t a bad thing.
However, in 1985, the real problems began.
See, as a result of all these currency wars,
the United States gained a fairly large external
deficit.
And because Washington politicians of the
time, as they do now, didn’t like it, they
forced the so-called "Plaza Accord", an agreement
between the United States, Japan, Germany,
France and the United Kingdom to depreciate
the dollar to decrease this trade defi
As you can imagine, this was a huge blow to
the Japanese industry, who was used to competing
with some help.
And, what do you think the government did?
It told them “Don’t worry, I’m here
to save you!"
And then the Japanese government sank its
interest rates and began boosting credit like
there was no tomorrow.
The result?
A huge debt spiral, banks distributing money
like crazy and a massive bubble in the real
estate and financial markets.
And, do you know what happened?
Well, in 1990, this entire house of cards
began to collapse...
In Germany, however, as we also saw here at
VISUALPOLITIK, the government opted to maintain
a strong Mark (their currency at that time),
which on one hand forced companies to compete
in productivity and innovation, but on the
other allowed them to buy foreign technology
and machines under better terms.
But, my friends, there’s still a third…
and determinant difference.
Listen up.
(LOCKED WITHIN THEMSELVES)
Japan is the most elderly country in the world.
Just over 25% of its population, that is,
1 in 4 Japanese are over 65; and for every
hour that passes, the country’s population
drops by 50 people.
You heard that right.
In fact, the Japanese government expects the
country's population to fall below 100 million
people by the year 2050.
And of course, the more elderly citizens there
are, the less young people, and the lower
population.
This has clear consequences:
For one, more public spending on pensions
and health care, and for another, less labor.
True, many other countries have this problem
but Japan’s case is by far the most serious.
And this isn’t at all by chance.
Japanese companies have compensated for all
the problems caused by the bad policies that
we went over in this video, forcing their
employees to work for longer hours than in
other developed countries... which obviously,
leaves very little time to think about starting
a family.
What’s more, while some countries, such
as Germany, have favored the arrival of immigrants,
who tend to have higher population growth
rates, Japan has closed its doors.
In fact, when international organizations
tell Japan that they have to open their borders
to immigration to face the aging problem…
the Japanese government has even said this:
(AUDIO: “Japan's finance minister tells
elderly they should 'hurry up and die' to
help reduce country's rising welfare bill”.
Daily Mail.)
So my friends, these are the fundamental causes
that have led Japan to live in continuous
crisis; and the causes that have made the
German model clearly better than the Japanese
model.
But now, it’s your turn.
Do you think Japan will manage to overcome
this stagnation and permanent crisis period?
Leave your answer in the comments as well
as in the survey.
I really hope you enjoyed this video, please
hit like if you did and don’t forget to
subscribe to our channel for brand new videos
every Monday and Thursday.
Also, don’t forget to check out our friends
at the Reconsider Media Podcast - they provided
the vocals in this episode that were not mine!
And as always, thanks for watching!